And to close out let's talk about some of the optimization tools that you can use in your project
So the console is a really useful thing to use in your projects
you can toggle a whole bunch of renderer quality settings and just
Pre-visualize some information that you might need to do so that can be opened by pressing the tilde key on your keyboard
Which is usually the top left button on your keyboard next to the number one key
You can open that console and type a bunch of commands in there to get the desired outcome
You can type help to open up all the different help
It'd be too much to go over in in this one course
But whether you want rendering when you want to export the rendering information to the screen or whether you want to see
How many sound files?
Being played at this time what is affecting tick or what's affecting the shadow maps or anything like this?
You can see a whole bunch of information here. You can really get granular with the console variables
so if you want to find them all just type in help and you'll get familiar with the go-to ones that you use on a
general basis here
Unreal also comes with some scalability settings. So
dependent on again the project and the platform
Here are some affordances you can make whether you want everything to always be set to epic or cinematic or whether you want it to
Automatically try and scale based on the platform
Maybe you want to set certain things to medium
But you really want foliage and shading to be at the best quality. It can be so you can
set them to epic for example, so a lot of
fine-grain information on how to
scale your settings here and you can also
Monitor the Reddit editor performance which the editor can say this is how your computer is running. Do you want to change the settings? So
useful things to keep in mind here and then also here's some
Different views of what it might look like if you go from low to medium to high and then to epic
So we also have a nanite auditing tool and the nanite auditing tool can tell you
What kind of mesh errors you get in with the static meshes it can tell you the the triangle count
So it might even be useful if you've imported this mesh
That's just got a crazy amount of triangles and you're thinking. Oh, I didn't I didn't realize that and it just it's a nice list
of
Previewing the information that's in your tool in your scene. Sorry, so
It tells you how many instances there are a certain mesh
So maybe you've got a really heavy mesh that you thought was being
Instanced more more than it wasn't and maybe you can make some
Affordance there again to kind of replace it with a mesh that's less expensive for example
And then it'll tell you the errors as well
So you can perform the audit there on the top left on the top right hand side. Sorry as well
You can just refresh the scene. So
Definitely worth checking out the the nanite auditing tool there and then we can also bulk edit assets
This is a really useful thing if you have gone through
Some of those
Say texture optimizations before and you think okay my textures weren't optimized before but now I want to
Go and edit all the textures to have this certain property now
You could double click on each texture and change it per instance
But that can be very time-consuming especially if you've got a lot of content in the project
This can work on static meshes. It can work on sound files
They can work on everything but essentially you can shift select multiple textures
In this example again, it can be any asset type and then you can right-click on the actual
Selected textures and you can go to asset actions and you can bulk edit via property matrix and this will give you any
common settings shared across the
You assets that you've selected in your content browser
so if there are all of the same asset type that it's going to give you a lot more options rather than if you selected a
Static mesh a sound cue and a texture for example
so there's a very very powerful tool for editing lots of content all at once and
Then also you can pin certain settings, which is quite useful to do especially if you're constantly using certain
Variables so in this instance because we've used textures the different compression settings
Like are all these normal maps set to be compressed as normal maps, for example, and so you can see a holistic level
What your content is doing? Do you need to edit anything?
Especially when we're looking at the
Texture compression settings, for example, do you want to go and check that all your normal maps in this instance?
They're all set to the correct compression. So very useful for getting a just an overview of everything that's going on in your content browser and
You can also package
Level instances as well. So if you've got say these four different meshes that you've placed together and you want to say, okay
I just want a singular instance of these you can actually create from the selection in the level instance tab and
Package level instance blueprint and hit okay
and that'll make some affordances for these four meshes that have been placed together and
Unreal will then make an optimization based on that. You can also merge actors together
So on our left hand side here
You can see all these static meshes have been
placed perfectly in the scene and there's 61 different meshes used here with 19 different materials and
51,000 triangles and so maybe we weren't hitting performance for some reason
Maybe there was just too many draw calls for these static meshes
now what we can actually do is we can right-click and we can merge the actors and
When we merge them we can actually make it just one draw call one static mesh and it actually has one
Material and it's still preserve the number of triangles. So if you still want to preserve that
visual bar
In terms of texture detail at least in terms of triangle detail. Sorry
Then you can merge these actors. So again, you can just right-click as selection of actors and merge those actors together and
If you see the merge actors property here
So when you are right-clicking the merge actors, you can see that what you're doing here is checking the merge method
so you what do you want to merge it to a single mesh actor and
Then you can change this setting and it'll tell you the components that are being merged and a
Useful tick box to know about on the bottom
Left hand side of that merge actors. Is that replace source actors?
So depends if you're trying to preserve the scene or not. So say you do replace source actors
From that previous example we saw it's going to replace all those 61 static meshes with one static mesh
But maybe that's not ideal for you see maybe you actually want to
Preserve all of those individual meshes, but you want to create a new version and place that new version somewhere else
So you may want to tick or untick that box
And again, you can just find the different settings that you want to use
The merge actors tool is very powerful tool
And again, if you're trying to bring down those draw calls might be worth checking out